Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There was a critic screening for a few Marvel
What If episodes recently
And during that, they showed teasers for three
upcoming Marvel animated series,
including X-Men 97 episodes, a Black Panther TV series
they've been making on the stealth called Eyes of Wakanda
and the Spider-Man Freshman Year Series.
they revealed a bunch about what's going on
with all those other series.
So we'll break it all down.
This video will mostly be with the X-Men 97 teaser, but
I will explain the other series during the video too.
if you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing videos for everything.
The next big episode will be for the
What If season two episodes.
That'll start next week. There'll be nine total.
I've already done a big trailer video for that,
so I'll link it at the end of this. But.
They finally confirmed the X-Men 97 episodes will
release in the spring next year after the Echo episodes.
And that Spider-Man Madame Web movie,
even though that's sort of like a Sony Marvel movie
and Marvel MCU stuff isn't totally involved with it,
at least as far as we know
It definitely seems like Sony wants to connect
what's going on in their Venom universe with the MCU.
And Madame Web is generally a multiverse character.
But X-Men 97 coming in the spring, quote unquote,
they didn't give an exact date.
Basically means between March and April.
And in the past,
Disney has really liked releasing stuff in March.
So I'm expecting March for right now.
But basically.
The series is meant to be X-Men,
the Animated series, Season six.
They're just calling it Season one of X-Men 97.
The reason why they use 97
is because had they not canceled X-Men,
the animated series after season five, Season
six would have aired in 1997.
but in the footage that they showed off recently
from episode one, the X-Men are interrogating Bolivar
Trask with Jean Gray
using her telepathy to probe his mind for the truth.
They used the Trask character during the live action
X-Men Days of Future Past Movie played by Peter
Dinklage.
His backstory was pretty similar during
that as it was the animated series in in the comics.
he's meant to be the scientist
that originally created the Sentinels,
during the new footage from episode one,
the new X-Men team mostly made up of members
from the original team with a couple of minor changes.
It's the leadership that changed they had on
an a mission to confront the threat of new sentinels.
Now, like brand new ones.
So that's why they're interrogating Trask again,
because he created the original ones.
they try to find out who's behind it.
And while they're on the mission, they make a bunch
of references to their training in the danger room.
So it sounds like there's a lot of danger room
in those early episodes.
Professor X is supposed to return eventually,
but episode one is mostly
the new team working together with Adam.
Like what is life
like with the X-Men without Professor X
they're basically picking up
where the original series left off.
And at the end of those original episodes
in the finale, Professor X almost died
after he was hit with an energy disruptor
at a mutant relations summit.
la land or comes to take him to the R empire
where they have technology to heal them.
And that's basically how they go out in the original
finale, like the X-Men and Magneto, watching him
leave in their absence,
Magneto tries to carry on his good name,
redeem himself in the process, helping the X-Men
standing in for Professor X as their new leader,
Storm and Cyclops are basically meant
to be like the day to day team leaders.
Even though Magneto is technically in charge of
everything, Jean Gray starts the season being pregnant.
I believe it's supposed to be with Kable, a.k.a.
Nathan Summers.
It sounds like she'll give birth to him
at some point during season one.
I don't think they want to begin season
two with her still being pregnant.
In the comics.
He's meant to be the son of Cyclops and Madeline Prior,
so a little bit of a different twist.
Who was a clone of Jean Gray,
who they thought had died, created by Mister
Sinister,
who was obsessed with Cyclops and Jean Gray's bloodline.
he believed that the children born of Cyclops
and Jean Gray
would become ultra powerful
Omega level mutants that he wanted for himself.
So he was obsessed with them during the original X-Men,
the animated series.
It sounds like they're continuing that during X-Men 97,
they'll probably be some Easter eggs
for the original comic book storyline, but like they did
a big cable storyline during the original X-Men.
The animated series is part of Apocalypse.
The storyline like he was time
traveling to try and kill Apocalypse,
deals with a big age of apocalypse
storyline during the original series.
So don't be surprised if we're seeing like
the young cable be born during these new episodes.
If we also see the older cable return at some point to.
Part of the reason why I think that storyline
is taking more center stage is because Mr.
Sinister himself
is supposed to be the main villain of season one.
At least it sounds like there'll be some larger plot
that he's involved in.
Like his plans will have gotten bigger
since the original series, but it usually just comes
back around to genetic experimentation
during the new trailer footage,
Cyclops also gets that classic Professor X Line,
which is also a comic book line, too.
To me, my X-Men generally, that's about all the footage
that they've revealed so far.
The new team mostly supposed to be the same
with a few minor changes like this is the roster here.
This new character is just a redesign of morph.
He's back on the main team.
Remember they found out he was still alive
and then eventually he turned good again.
a lot of people confused about this character too.
This is just meant to be sunspot
The original writers explain what would have happened
had they continued the regular show back in the day
and they got in season six in It
sounds like the plot of X-Men 97 is basically
that like they just literally continued
with what happens to the X-Men a couple of months
after Professor X leaves the Earth,
They've already been a couple big X-Men
animated series, Easter eggs in the live action
Marvel movies and Disney Plus series recently.
The biggest ones being Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness when they introduced
Patrick Stewart in the A38 universe
as part of the Illuminati, his character design
was meant to look exactly like Professor X
from the animated series.
they even played the song from the animated series.
Generally, all
the X-Men characters in the A3 universe,
not just the one that you see here,
are meant to be based on X-Men, the animated series
versions of the characters And speaking of X-Men,
I obviously just did a big video for the Deadpool
three Wolverine scenes
with the classic X-Men
that came back from the first X-Men movie.
Like there are a bunch of deep cuts
from the X-Men movies in that movie.
we'll also see a bunch of them
come back during Secret Wars, I think just depending on
how Deadpool three does their wedding,
this is sort of like a Spider-Man.
No way home for the X-Men movies. X-Men.
No way home. It if it does well,
they'll bring more of them back during secret wars in.
If it doesn't do well, then just be a couple of them,
like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine coming back
during the Ms..
Marvel series, you may have heard
when they were revealing that she was also a mutant,
they also played the X-Men,
the animated series theme music.
and speaking of Ms.
Marvel, we literally just saw the Marvel's movie
Post-Credits scene where Monica Rambeau wound up
in the alternate X-Men universe
with this version of Kelsey
Grammer's Beast from the original X-Men movies.
so Kevin Feige clearly wants people thinking of X-Men
in the original series.
For those of you asking whether or not it's
going to be canon to the MCU, though,
generally you're supposed to look at it
the way we look at what if being canon to the MCU,
like technically it is canon,
but it's all happening in different universes.
So X-Men, the animated series is canon,
but it is happening in an alternate universe.
they'll probably release like the full, larger trailer
after the Echo episodes premiere in January.
So look out for that.
Of course, I'll do a video for whatever
they wind up releasing And thankfully, they did confirm
that they're already recording
like they're working on X-Men 97 season two.
That probably will release sometime during 2025.
Hopefully it doesn't get pushed to like 2026.
Don't wait too long before we actually see that.
they also confirmed that they're working on
what if season three right now that will release
sometime during 2025 hopefully because we have
all of these X-Men Fantastic Four characters coming in.
They'll put some of them in the
what if episodes and fully
take advantage of the whole concept of the
What If series.
The other big.
2024 Marvel Animated Series
they released teasers for were the Black Panther Eyes
of Will Condor series, which is like a stealth series
they've been working on in the background.
Apparently the official synopsis
they released is Throughout Wakandan history,
Brave warriors have been tasked to travel the world
retrieving dangerous vibranium artifacts.
This is their story that makes it sound like
it'll be about a special group inside the door. M.J.
or another group of special warriors who go around
the world just hunting down vibranium weapons, artifacts
that have fallen into the hands of villains
over the years, look, that ancient vibranium weapon
that Killmonger found in the museum
during the first Black Panther movie, stuff like that.
But across the ages.
So we'll see many different versions of Black Panther
from across the years.
my assumption right now,
because that's like the next series after X-Men
97 is that that will release summer 2024.
They also confirmed that the Spider-Man freshman year
series will premiere in 2024.
So by default,
that basically means it'll air at the end of 2024.
they also changed the official title of that.
And now it's called Friendly Neighborhood Spider-Man.
I'm not sure why they did that.
Maybe to avoid a little bit of confusion
because of the way the continuity is going to work,
because there's some of it that's canon to the MCU,
like it's meant to be Tom Holland's Spider-Man
freshman year.
But a lot of the details of the series are different.
A lot of the events of his backstory
are different to a really good example
is that Norman Osborn and Harry
Osborn are a big part of his story during that
in, for example, this is the Captain America
Civil War scene that we saw in theaters,
But it's Norman Osborn instead of Tony Stark, Iron Man
Nico Minoru, who you probably remember from Runaways,
is a big part of that. Dr.
Strange is a big part of it too.
Benedict Cumberbatch, I think, is supposed to be doing
The Voice in Charlie Cox's coming back
as his version of Daredevil. During it.
they even animated the series
in the style of Steve Ditko classic Spider-Man art.
So it looks really cool to I've already done
a much longer trailer video
for that Spider-Man freshman year series,
so I'll link it at the end of this.
But it looks like it's going to be pretty solid.
and because they revealed their full 2024
animated slate,
that essentially means that the Marvel Zombies
season one is pushed to 2025.
Like I said, I'm also assuming that X-Men 97 Season
two will also be 2025 as is.
What if season three?
But everyone.
Posts all your reactions in the comments below
to all this new footage
and let me know which other animated series
do you want them to do?
The sky is literally the limit.
They can do anything that they want in animation.
No worries about the budget.
really hoping to see more Fantastic four more X-Men
animated stuff happening in the next couple of years.
Now they're rolling out that stuff out in live action
the probably be a couple more.
What if season two trailer video
so I'll post those as soon as they release them
and click here for that Spider-Man
Freshman year trailer video
and click here for my other
What if Season 2 trailer video and Easter Eggs
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!